hallo sportfreunde heute am dienstag
machen wir mit euch einen kraft ausdauer
hat wirklich zum unterschied zu gestern
gestern war der fokus auf der rumpf
kraft das heißt alles was zum bauch und
zurück muskulatur gehört wir die nikita
herbert und ich der beta wir wünschen
euch einen wunderschönen vormittag und
hoffen jetzt fit für das heutige
programm für das heutige workout ich
gesagt geht es los
bengalos einmal bewegen am stand das
kennt man bereits das ist nichts neues
er läuft locker war mir läuft locker ein
wir haben gestern dabei gehabt dass arme
kreisen das machen wir jetzt halt dazu
das heißt einmal rechte hand vorwärts
kreisen linke hand vorwärts kreisen nur
die linke danke beide arme vorwärts
kreisen die ihre echte rückwärts greifen
und er merkt sie mir schon wieder gut
aufpassen ist mittendrin statt nur dabei
sein
was macht man fehler und das will man
natürlich nicht linke hand rückwärts
greifen und beide rückwärts kreisen
genauer aus lockern oberkörper verdrehen
linke auf die rechte seite hinüber
drehen
so hat die bewegungs amplitude zu
verändern ein mal mehr mal weniger aber
könnte den kopf mitnehmen die blick
wendung mitmachen arme los den kopf in
einer neutralen position dass man recht
im bereich der heiß wir so ein bisserl
mitnehmen
genau wie gesagt noch einmal vorher
neutral position vom kopf und trotzdem
den oberkörper drehen
das ist dann mal nach vor und drehst den
oberkörper dazu genau genauso jetzt
setzt chrysler bewegung auch im bereich
der heiße duelle mit drinnen und wir
laufen wieder locker am stand
beziehungsweise bleiben
den boxer laufen dann haben wir schon
immer gemacht den man mit dazu herein
genau gerade schläge auswärts lege seit
tagen alles ist möglich
ihr kennt ja immer wieder grades knie
dazu anheben als wir waren ja aus dem
militärischen boxen ankick mit einbauen
das hat nicht so schnell nicht so
hektisch einfach haben wir locker zum
aufwärmen
das heutige training wird von der
intention
wahrscheinlich habe es noch
anstrengender wie das gestrige das heißt
es muss er das aufwärmen ein bisschen
intensiver werden okay aus locker drauf
einstellen 55 kniebeugen 56 jetzt 5
liege stets beginnen dann sofort wieder
auf fünf kniebeugen 23 45 und auf die
matte fünf sie tabs
sehr gut und wieder auf und wir bewegen
uns wieder lockeres boxen am stand haben
wir nur den oberkörper mit am stand das
heißt die beine fixieren aber nur am
standboxen körper dazu rollen
entsprechende gewichtsverlagerungen
einbauen
einfach das maßen oberkörper wirklich
schön mobil und und aufgewärmt dann ins
werk gehen können
kerner und wir wechseln ja wieder in
einen lauf am stand und jetzt waren wir
nur vierte übung dazu ein das heißt wir
im kopf die fünf liegestütz die fünf
kniebeugen die fünf sie tabs und fünf
für den rücken das aufrichten in der
bauchlage macht mir keiner dazu dass
ganze bezeichnet macht aus vier mal fünf
okay ich sowas 455 liegestütz 5
und fünfmal den rücken ausrichten heißt
bau klage genau man jetzt cancellara
unten bleiben irgendwie liegestütz
ausgangsstellung gehen und zehn sekunden
klein war geht's los knie zur brust
dynamisch vor und zurück drei zwei eins
raus und wieder auf ghana jetzt schauen
wir mal dass dieses jahres
kreislaufsystem die atmung sind wieder
normalisiert weil wir sagen immer noch
aufwärmen trainer wenn sie intensiver
wird aber es ist immer noch das
aufwärmprogramm das heißt wir fangen
wieder an mit dem becken kreisen kleine
kreise aus dem becken die handy gerne in
die hüfte verschränken und immer größer
werden und sobald man die volle
bewegungs amplitude haben wir haben in
der anderen richtung drehe immer die
richtung und wärme wieder kleiner
genau
gehen wir gleich in eine ganz eine
schmale stand position ist eine
schließen hände aufs knie und da mal das
knie rotieren dass man entlang vom
kniegelenken bislang mobilisation mit
hineinbringen richtung wechseln und 45
das heisst 5 5
die beiden 50 bis 54 rücken das heißt
drücken aufrichten und ihr seht vom
zusatzgerät was ich gesagt habe was man
entsprechend brauchen wir heute
wir haben unsere der agenda vorbereitet
wir haben eine wasserflasche vorbereitet
wir haben aktuell vorbereitet um einfach
zu zeigen welche unterschiedlichen
möglichkeiten das bei dem werk hat es
auch gibt zwar auch jetzt
abgeschlossenen 54 rücken ohne reißen
und wieder auf letzte übung im warmup
wir machen noch hochstrecke sprünge fünf
stück an der zahl geht schon los
eins zwei drei vier und fünf
aufwärmen sollte erledigt sein herz
kreislauf system ist angekommen oder ja
ich habe ja gesagt wir starten wieder
mit der ersten übung wir machen wieder
30 sekunden übungszeit und 30 sekunden
pause zeit wie gesagt wer möchte kann
gerne die übungszeit verlängern und
dadurch die pause zeit verkürzen
das ist alles in ordnung wir machen 30
30 so dass ihr mit zwei
unterschiedlichen übungs varianten etwas
schwerer etwas leichter da einfach
supercool mit trainieren können erste
übung rudern im sitzen das heißt einmal
mit dem theraband sagt euch die nici vor
ihr seid am boden
nehmt das theraband in einer position so
dass es gut um die füße und umgeben
kannst gereift zu sein
hebt die fersen vom boden ab und streckt
eure beine aus genau heute spannung und
wieder zurück kurz spannung halten und
wieder vor das ist die eine variante
zweite variante
machen wir das selbe ihr zuhause mit der
wasserflasche oder mit beiden
wasserflaschen und beine strecken und
wieder anwinkeln und der herbert sagt
euch das jetzt vor mit der wasserflasche
machen wir das dann aber schon mit der
kette bell 21 los gehts 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit und das jetzt auch beim
theraband es gibt beim theraband
unterschiedliche farben es gibt grün es
gibt trauer es gibt ziel war es gibt
gold es gibt unterschiedlichste
varianten die zeigen euch habe zudem
intensität den schwierigkeitsgrad den
widerstand des bandes an drei sekunden
21 aus erste variante erste übung
mannschaft so bizeps da große muskel
hoffentlich groß im oberarm
der hat den arm beugt wir machen wir
sind da der band variante guter stand
spannung so aufbauen anbandelt dass man
schöne widerstand hat nicht gesagt wir
vor und nach oben ziehen und wieder
runter gehen
herbert macht das ganze mit der kette
bell kennst dann gleich schauen 21 uhr
los geht's kontrolliert die bewegungen
atmen nicht vergessen
spannung in der muskulatur aufbauen und
am besten die 30 sekunden immer her
gehen die spannung die bleibt 30
sekunden aufrecht und wie man schon
gesagt habe aus dem rumpf training
heraus die grundspannung bauchmuskulatur
rückenmuskulatur bleibt immer vorhanden
immer die kiwis nicht her
in 321 30 sekunden hat schon wieder die
nächste übung wir zeigen dass vor ist
das rudern in der vorbeuge okay da
herbert macht das ganze mit der kette
bälle genau und zähigkeit aubel nach
oben
wir nehmen zu ihre wasserflaschen
vorbereitet und die nicht gemacht das
ganze mit dem theraband in zehn sekunden
gehts los
ok setzt es wichtig dabei ist an
stabilen rücken zu haben ja bauchmuskeln
rückenmuskeln gespannt
21 und los gehts nicht dafür die bieten
kannst du ganz schnell um 90 grad drehen
dass man deinen rücken aussehen genau
ist jetzt perfekte rücken spannung da
ist 100% muskelkraft die da arbeitet und
den körper in der spannung hält in jeder
bewegung rauf runter
die spannung ist da gerne sehen sie
konnten wie gesagt die wasserflasche
ziehen ein zusatzgewicht einen kübel 63
mineralwasser alles okay sei das aus 30
sekunden sind vorbei und ich habe es
schon gesagt ich sage es gerne noch
einmal in jedes militärische workout
kern liegestütze und das ist auch unser
nächste übung das heißt 30 sekunden
liegestütz ihr wisst dass bereits die
leichtere variante ist an der mauer
angelehnt oder am knie abgelegt die
schwierige ist normale komplexe
liegestütz in der standard variante mit
viel körperspannung 3 2 1 los geht's da
kann man natürlich auch mit dem tempo
variieren das heißt wenn man schneller
wird ist das natürlich noch viel
belastender 30 sekunden zu arbeiten als
wie war man entsprechend da es ja auch
pausen gönnt oben oder unten
ihr habt es noch zehn sekunden ja
durchbeißen noch 3 2 eine und
liegestütze ist wieder vorbei sei wir
schnappen uns wieder das theraband oder
unserer zusatzgewicht und machen eine
übung für den tritt selbst in den arm
strecke das heißt eben auch mal ein arm
ich das heißt nicht beide gleichzeitig
sondern wir wechseln dann von links auf
rechts wir starten mit rechts
ihr habt es nur 15 sekunden zeit in die
position spannung aufbauen ellbogen nach
oben und dann entsprechend strecken und
es kann natürlich mit jedem
zusatzgewicht machen oder auch mit dem
theraband 321 zeit läuft 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit jetzt und also wie die
letzten tage ist es natürlich auch heute
so der doktor aussitzt und beantwortet
geduldig alle fragen zum sport
zu hause vorm pc das heißt scheut euch
nicht auch entsprechende fragen zu
stellen
ihr habt es noch zehn sekunden
arbeitszeit körperspannung halten bauch
treibt und der spanierin rücken bleibt
unter spannung arbeiten gespannt wird
der trizeps weise konnten eine rund
pause aus lockern position wechseln
zweite seite vorbereitet wie geht es mit
der kette bei christof berger also jedes
zusatzgewicht jemand was irgendwo fans
und greifen kennste haben damit kann man
diesen übungen alle sehr gut machen und
da käme es einfach wählen so dass die
intensität für euch passt dass ihr diese
30 sekunden arbeiten clans vorbereiten
los gehts wieder auch da wiederum
wichtig die bauchmuskulatur ist gespannt
der rücken ist gespannt und ihr atme
zweiter ja nicht pressen sondern atmen
genau konzentriert sein
ja was macht stück ist eine abwandlung
jetzt mit einer schule press versuchen
ein album wirklich ruhig zu halten und
dann das nach oben zu gehen das gewicht
ja super und seit 30 sekunden auslagern
kurze pause jetzt kommt eine kombinierte
übung aus beinen und armen
das hast du machen eine kniebeuge und
gehen dann in die komplette strecke mit
den armen nach oben das kniebeuge mit
arm stoßen nicht dafür bieten dass du
uns das einmal vor zeigst genau
vorbereiten runter in die kniebeuge hoch
und durch strecken genau da müssen wir
das mal ausprobieren dass sie die
spannung aber wirklich findet die ihr
braucht bereitmachen 21 uhr los geht's
genau wie gesagt ganz wichtig atmens
leute lasst die luft aus den co2 aus und
den sauerstoff rein so ist richtig dass
die muskulatur an wirklich gescheit
arbeiten kann
das ist sehr komplex
die gescheit gas bereitmachen 21 uhr
pause 30 sekunden geschafft wir wechseln
jetzt wiederum in eine bauch übung das
heißt einmal ohne zusatzgerät für die
nickel und einmal mit dem zusatzgerät
hotel für ein herbert dass der geht es
in die ausgangsstellung und wie man hier
sieht das machen
das ist aber kasse position genau in die
ausgangsstellung wie wenn ihr sie tipps
machen wolltet nehmt eure wasserflasche
oder auch nicht lass das weg und dreetz
den oberkörper von links auf rechts geht
schon los
genau wichtig bei der übung leute ganz
ganz wichtig die volle spannung da
wieder aus der rückenmuskulatur
dort muss stabil sein dass sie mir nicht
weh tut dass sie den maximalen
trainingserfolg habe und ohne
zusatzgewicht setzte das da funktioniert
das genau so gut da kann ein bisschen
der schräglage im oberkörper nehmen und
die bauchmuskulatur arbeit ist gefordert
und wird mit trainiert fünf sekunden die
30 sekunden sagen gleich vorbei jetzt
bau klage geht herbert wasserflasche
greifen
das heißt ihr nehmt sich eine
wasserflasche her und geht es mit der
wasserflasche in vorhalte einmal vor und
jetzt wechselt als einarmiger auf die
rückseite gibt das durch genau
übernehmen und wieder vor
das ist die komplexe variante 30
sekunden lang arbeiten
die zweite variante kennt er schon aus
die wir aus den trainings wir heben den
oberkörper vom boden weg 21 uhr los
geht's hintern ist angespannt kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule die füße
könnte abheben oder am boden lassen das
ist mit spannung aus dem hintern heraus
beide varianten möglich noch 12 sekunden
10 sekunden
321 selber die letzte übung im ersten
durchgang
manchmal für die schulter das heißt wir
haben die schulter in der vorbeuge wo
man die arme seitlich weg bewegen nicht
wir brauchen uns kürze eine
wasserflasche aus ja ich gebe dem
herbert eine zweite wasserflasche in die
hand der kamera wieder kleinere variante
aufnehmen weil die übung geht richtig in
die schultermuskulatur rein da ist die
erna halb kilo wasserflasche vielleicht
sogar zu schwer
ja er geht es in eine vorreiterin einer
vorbeuge und bewegt die hände seitlich
nach oben schaut dabei dass die bewegung
so ausschaut das ungefähr auf kopfhöhe
mit den armen nach vorkommen das heißt
nicht so weit zurückziehen bereit machen
die exakt länger als 30 sekunden zeit
mit dem theraband oder mit der
wasserflasche
beide varianten super dort setzte wieder
immer schauen diese grundposition der
gerade rücken der stabile rücken mit
voller spannung das ist es absolut
wichtig für euch beim training sehen sie
konnten er wird nach 321 und übungs
pause zehn übungen heimmannschaft den
ganzen körper einmal durchtrainiert das
manchmal kurze satz pause und nach der
pause
manchmal die gleichen übungen noch
einmal jetzt sollte ungefähr auch im
bild sein wie viel gewicht wie viel
zusatz belastung brauche so dass sie gut
trainieren kann dass sie mit überfordern
aber einheitlich unter fordere ja und
noch einmal als hinweis für morgen
morgen haben wir einen leistungssportler
bei uns dabei das heißt wir haben den
korporal wagner da der ein jogger ist
ein erfolgreicher stocker und dem
österreichischen bundesheers
leistungssportler tätig ist und die
erwartungs morgen an coolen einblick in
seine trainings variante krafttraining
geben und da vor allem auch wieder viel
mit dem eigenen körpergewicht das heißt
am morgen gute trainingseinheit mit dem
korporal wagen als leistungssportler bei
niki und mir der herr baird hat morgen
pause und steigt dann am mittwoch wieder
hin
genau beziehungsweise am donnerstag
steigt er wieder hin
ja ok braucht man auch einmal wieder
loslegen mit 30 sekunden noch bereit
anstatt mal in 30 sekunden mit der
ersten übung wieder und zwar das war das
rudern im sitzen genau position
einnehmen bereit machen und los gehts 30
sekunden arbeitszeit ab jetzt
körperspannung halten länger und mit
zusatzgewicht wird es schon richtig
richtig anstrengend wurde das jetzt das
thema band ist oder ob das die kette
bell ist das ist körperlich richtig
intensiv zwei sekunden nur dann sollen
die ersten 30 durch
das ok position wechseln entstehen der
bizeps ist wieder dran
der anteilige macht sich bereit findet
eure position trotz dass die richtige
spannung im theraband drinnen habe es
nicht zu viel nicht zu wenig fünf
sekunden und los geht s 30 sekunden
bizeps curls und los geht's wichtig
dabei gut muskulärer stand sieg beim
herbert perfekt der hat einen leichten
winkel in seinem knie drinnen
der ist mit voller power aus dem aus dem
körper heraus aus der rumpf mitte heraus
und zieht opel wirklich mit der kraft
seiner oberarme nach oben
fünf sekunden hat es nur zeit 21 und 30
sekunden
wir bleiben gleich im stehen und gehen
ins rudern in der vorbeuge position
finden spannung finden wie oft muss oder
wie kurz oder lang nehme ich meinen
widerstandsband beim herbert ist leute
geld ist immer gleich schwer
es verändert sie nicht noch fünf
sekunden bereit machen und arbeiten
rudern in der vorbeuge voll gesperrt da
wieder aus dem raum voraus ganz wichtig
atmen nicht vergessen
und wie gesagt die 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit
die ist schon nicht so intensiv dass
gibt gas noch 5 sekunden und sei dass 30
sekunden sommer wieder durch wir
wechseln auf die liegestütze
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass zum thema
liegestütze noch fragen gibt aber wie
gesagt klar wiederhole ich mich auch
gern der doktor aus der
sportwissenschaftler des sportzentrums
sitzt vorm pc und beantwortet auch die
anfragen zu liegestützen oder wozu auch
immer wir machen wir reden nicht darüber
wir machen sondern niki bereit habe
bereits fünf sekunden 321 und
liegestütze auch gerne hier wieder die
erinnerung an die variante an der mauer
angelehnt waren die belastung am boden
zu hoch wird noch einmal den winkel
kürzer den hebel kürzer oder den winkel
verändert ich dass wir das gescheit
arbeiten kann
30 sekunden durch arbeiten mit
liegestütze ist nämlich ganz schön
anstrengend zehn sekunden leute angst
zwar gas geben zehn sekunden liegestütz
gleich ob das aufstehen und er merkt 30
sekunden liegestütz belastet die
muskulatur schon mal ganz stark und da
ist ein rezept nicht ausgenommen
und damit man gleich richtig unter
belastung und an der feier haben wie es
so schön heißt machen wir die übung
drauf für das arme strecken damit sie
richtig belastend für den trizeps ist
wenn man kann natürlich über die
steuerung war nicht welche übungen auch
noch einmal die intensität verstärken
oder ein bisschen rausnehmen indem er
ein wechsel drinnen habt jetzt sitzt die
verstärkte variante dreht selbst geht
schüler aus 30 sekunden
die vorbelastung von den liegestütz
spürbar niki leicht spürbar
ja bei dir
ja schon spürbar ich glaube dass also
das ist das gibt was aber in 10 sekunden
gut hauptsatz schon wieder dann kann man
die hand wechseln
er hat immer mit einem dienst freudigen
lächeln natürlich genau hand wechseln
aus lockern zweite seite vorbereiten und
natürlich in der pause knapp zu einer
wasserflasche trinkt einen schluck wenn
ihr also eine harmlos wie wir sie doch
haben diese grünen wasserflaschen
natürlich gerne nehmen an der verlosung
teil
teils denn das video kommentiertes video
untersatz mit in der verlosung dabei
und ihr kennt danach habe die chance auf
eine bundesheer wasserflasche drei
sekunden geht schon los und zeit läuft
tritt selbst der arm strecke die letzte
wiederholung für diese muskulatur
ja man sich dann schon wenn es
körperlich richtig richtig anstrengend
wird dass man teilweise als ausweich das
heißt ein bisschen kleinere bewegungen
schauen wir dass mein ellbogen wirklich
schön stabil halten fünf sekunden und
sein aus kurze pause kurz durchschnaufen
position wechseln kniebeuge mit anstoßen
15 sekunden bereitmachen spannung wählen
aber vielleicht ausprobieren mit dem
theraband die übungen ob die spannung
des bundles passt das nicht zu viel oder
zu wenig ist fünf sekunden bereit 21 und
los geht's gerne schlafen atmen bewegung
server ausführen spannung aus der
rumpfmuskulatur es sagen die letzten
nach der übung die letzten drei den man
auch an die letzten drei übungen dann
ist das workout für heute wieder
geschichte wobei stimmt da nicht ganz
kennt das natürlich jederzeit auf
youtube nach sehen wir uns das in ruhe
trainieren wird jeder zeit statt 30
sekunden sind vorbei wir wechseln in die
opposition
die nie gelacht ja vorher war die
falsche position erster die richtige
position oberkörper schräglage nach
hinten und welt verdrehen den körper
nach links und rechts nimmt eine
wasserflasche nimmt ein zusatzgewicht
oder macht zwar ohne dar auch wenn er
belastet wird frites und das passiert in
fünf sekunden was der herr über das
bereite hat sein gewicht und los jetzt
30 sekunden arbeitszeit schöne rücken
haltung schultern zurück sind stolzer
brust machen denn dann wird es richtig
schwierig 15 sekunden
nach fünf sekunden
und zeit aus 30 sekunden pause ihr könnt
sind die bauchlage wechseln entspannen
kurz wasserflasche hernehmen und die
wasserflasche wieder übergeben
da kann es natürlich auch die übungs
variante wieder oberkörper hochheben
holzhacker kraulbeine wir haben so viel
rückenübungen stück macht wichtig ist
dass der rücken belastet wird jetzt
oberkörper hoch heben in 21 und los
geht's und wie gesagt wasserflasche
übergeben ist er super variante um
einerseits die beweglichkeit in der
schulter mitzutrainieren andererseits
die kraft zu trainieren den rücken den
oberkörper entsprechend zu halten und so
kleine hilfsmittel findet man zu hause
eigentlich überall und immer ein paar
sekunden hat es nur fünf sekunden
belastungs zeit noch 212 das aus einmal
noch aus lockern einmal noch ausstehen
wir gehen in die letzte übung der
schulter heben in der vorbeuge genau
zwei wasserflaschen resistent ein
theraband als hilfsmittel wichtig dabei
ist wieder oberkörper in der vorbeuge
volle spannung aus der rumpfmuskulatur
verrückten ist in seinem die wirbelsäule
ist in ihrem natürlichen schwung
muskulär abgesichert geht's los
genau da kennt man schauen dass man die
hand wie sie weiter vorgeht und seitlich
hochzieht dann kann man da wirklich ganz
ganz stark in den oberen rücken hinein
und wie gesagt beide varianten sind
möglich ob das theraband oder die
wasserflasche das ist gerne genug
belastung dar sekunden arbeitszeit noch
fünf sekunden als wiederholungen ging es
hinaus und sei aus
30 sekunden sind vorbei ihr habt es
geschafft zwei durchgänge zehn übungen
jeweils 30 sekunden belasten
30 sekunden pause das war die vorgabe
mit zusatzbelastung oder ohne
zusatzbelastung also widerstandsband
cable wasserflasche oder auch ohne
jeweils mit dabei uns hat es sehr
gefreut die nici ja hat passt für die
von der belastung her wird für die was
anstrengend oder als abo anstrengend
aber heute passt genau morgen noch kann
man also wiederholung morgen kommt unser
leistungssportler der korporal wagner zu
uns und macht mit euch ein krafttraining
mit eigenen körpergewicht und dann
schauen wir weiter wie es wissen was die
woche noch gibt am donnerstag military
fitness und am freitag noch mehr
beweglichkeit zum abschluss dann haben
wir die woche wieder erledigt dann ist
wieder gute trainingswoche ja ab
trainiert hätte man gesagt mir jetzt
freut dass ihr dabei war und ich freue
mich auf morgen schönen tag noch